so i can tell you
from my personal experience one of the
best
educated lessons i got was when i got
to meet trump so i interviewed trump
four different times
as a journalist spent like two and a
half hours with him
in the oval office not alone but like me
and one person and like the press
secretary and that was it so i actually
got to observe him
and as a guy who reads these types of
books right and you know you think of
trump
obviously most people what they see on
television you know in articles and more
but being able to observe it like
one-on-one i was closer to him than you
know than i am
right now from you that was
one of the most educational experiences
i got because it's like you just said
the look the leaning forward the way
he talks he the way he is a master
at taking the question and answering
exactly which part he wants and then if
you try and follow up he's like excuse
me
you know like he knows and then whenever
you're talk
it's not that he's annoyed about getting
interrupted if he
realizes he's been miranda and then you
interrupt him all good but if he's
striving home a point which he has to
make sure appears in your transcript
or whatever it's it's like it really was
fascinating for me
to look at and what was also crazy with
trump
is i realized how much he was living in
the moment so like when i went to the
oval
you know i've read all these biographies
and like i walk in i'm like
holy [ __ ] oh you're like i'm in the oval
office well you're interviewing him in
the oval
in the oval every time was in the office
you scared shitless sorry well
i wasn't scared i was just look it's the
oval office right i mean
i'm this nerd he was like this kid i
when i'm so
i'll admit this here like i printed out
on my dad's label maker when i was like
seven and i wrote like the oval office
on my bedroom so i was like you know a
huge
nerd like obviously eagle maniacal even
from seven
but so like for this i mean it was huge
right i'm like this 25 year old kid and
like i walk in there
and like i see the couch right and i'm
like oh man like that's
kissinger like you know i'm like that's
where like kissinger and nixon got on
their knees
and you see over by the door and you're
like are the scuff marks still there
from when eisenhower used to play
you know this is all running through my
mind yeah trump none of those there none
of it right so like
even the desk i put my phone on the desk
to record yeah and i'm like this is the
[ __ ] resolution
like i shouldn't put my phone on this
thing yeah and
and i'm like hms resolute you know all
the international even for him
he doesn't think about any of it it was
like amazing to me like he had this
portrait of andrew jackson
right next to his to the uh i think from
on the fireplace like right here on the
right
and the most revealing question was when
i was like mr president what are people
going to remember you for in 100 years
and he was like he had he was like i
don't know like veteran's choice
he like has a list in front of him of
like his
accomplishments which is a question by
the way yeah well i
i mean that's what i wanted to know and
he's like veteran's choice and i
remember looking at him being like
it's not going to be better i'm like i'm
looking at you
donald trump the harbinger of something
new yeah we still don't know what the
hell it is
and so i realized with these guys and
their charisma and more is that they
don't think about themselves the way
that we think about them and that was
actually important to understand because
a lot of people like trump is playing
all this chess i'm like i assure you
he's not like he's
truly one time i was interviewing him
and he had like a certificate that he
had to sign or something on his desk
he's like it was like child almost like
he got distracted by he's like oh what's
this you know
it's like picking up and i was like wow
like this this is the guy
like this is what he is well i wonder if
there was a different
person because you're recording and then
it's like offline and i can tell you
well here's the thing though because
that's another part of it because
that two hours i would say like half
that was not on the record
so like whenever he's off the record he
changes
completely right i i don't want to like
go into too much of it or whatever but
like
he uh i mean he is
so mindful of when that camera is on and
when the mic is hot
in terms of the language that he uses
what he's willing to admit
what he's willing to talk about how he's
willing to even appear
in front of his staff um i think the
most revealing thing trump ever did
was there was this press conference like
right after he lost you the
right after the midterm elections of
2018. and one of the journalists was
like mr president
thank you for doing this press
conference and he looks at him and he
goes
it's called earn media it's worth
billions he just he just
like had so much disdain for him because
he's like i'm not doing this for you
he's like i'm doing this for me
so he's really aware of the narrative
story i mean that
the people have talked about that all
comes from the tabloid media of
the from new york and so on he's a
master of that
but i've also heard stories of just in
private
he's a really i don't want to overuse
the word charismatic but just like
he is a really interesting almost
like um friendly like a good person
like like that's what i heard uh i've
heard actually surprisingly the same
thing about hillary clinton
and like that i can't tell you but like
the
the way they present themselves is
perhaps
very different than they are as human
beings one-on-one that that's something
uh
maybe that's just like a skill thing
maybe
maybe the way they present themselves in
public is actually their
their uh i mean almost their real self
and they're just really good in private
one-on-one
to go into this mode of just being
really
intimate in some kind of human way i
think that's part of it because i
would notice that with trump you know
he's like it's almost like a tour guide
it was very like it's it's very crazy
right because you're like you're in the
oval i mean it's his office
and he's like he's like do you guys want
anything he's like you want a diet coke
because he drinks like all this diet
coke
that's like you know what he's great
apologizing yeah he's just like
he's like you guys want a diet coke
right and you're sitting there and
you're like
the way he he's able to like like
the last time he interviewed him he he
wanted to do it outside
um because he like he's studied himself
from all angles and he knows exactly how
he looks on a camera and with the witch
lighting
and so we were supposed to interview him
on camera in the oval office which is
actually
rare like you don't usually get that and
they ended up moving it outside at the
last minute
and he came out and he's like i picked
this spot for you it's like great
lighting
yeah i was like because you are your own
like lightning director
yeah the president is great it's so
funny
but it's like you said he's he's very
charismatic
and it friendly i mean you wouldn't i
mean look
this is what i mean in terms of the
dynamism of these people
that gets lost and i think even he knows
that like i don't think he would want
that side of him
that i see you know that you've seen
those off the record moments and more
in order to come out because he's very
keen about
how exactly he presents to the public
it's like you know even his presidential
portrait
everybody usually smiles and he refused
to smile he was like i want to look like
winston churchill
you know like even he knew that
you